You're collecting information like it's
going to save you. It won't. The
smartest people I know aren't the ones
who read the most. They're the ones who
stopped lying to themselves first. Your
IQ doesn't matter if your ego keeps
vetoing your intelligence. I spent years
reading books about productivity while
procrastinating, studying relationship
advice while repeating the same
mistakes. I had information. What I
didn't have was the ruthlessness to
apply it to myself. Your brain can't
tell the difference between a threat and
an opportunity.
Asking for a raise and being chased by a
predator produce almost identical
responses. That's not wisdom. That's an
evolutionary glitch. Failure isn't the
opposite of success. It's the tuition.
Knowledge comes from books. Wisdom comes
from scars. Someday isn't a day of the
week, and you've been scheduling things
there for years. The gap between knowing
and doing is where your entire life is
decided.